Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina Vincent?
No,
no.
Mommy.
Okay.
No,
you made your eyes now
your mom and your mom's mom
jeans.
[inaudible]
you're making quite a bit.
Yeah.
Well I wouldn't have a problem if I was wearing it.
How dare you breathing made that for you.
I ordered it on Amazon using our banner.
Your mom's.
How are you guys doing?
Thank you for coming out tonight.
Ooh,
you gotta make sure this thing,
stop it.
Hi Guys,
this is so exciting.
A Sunday night.
Holy Shit Man.
You don't give a fuck about your lives is awesome.
Snacks,
amount of fame.
All right.
Yeah,
you got it.
You ordered.
I have not seen this.
I,
this was not a set up.
She was like,
I have a surprise for you.
And then
she came out with a fucking nerd hat.
Fucking water nerd.
That's what you are chief of the water nerves.
Look at you.
Those little bottles of too much for you to handle it.
How dare you look at you dehydrating with coffee right now.
But then I drank yet,
lady,
you're terrible.
You need to get fucking life.
So this is so exciting.
I can't handle a,
by the way,
how many of you read the early taping?
A early shot.
Wow.
Diehard moms die hard wall to wall mart really to get your life now.
You bet it gets your life now.
Um,
no,
we had a lot of fun at that show.
We explored some interesting topics,
but we have many more non binary topics,
very nonbinary topics.
You know what's so interesting about the non binary thing is that we thought
we'd get a lot of push back on the last episode,
you know,
so we've been asking people,
hey,
hi.
How are you?
What's your name?
What's your pronouns?
So
the idea
conversations that way is insanity.
Yeah.
They,
you should meet people and be like,
hey,
hey.
Hi.
What's your name?
What's your Pronoun that you would do?
Well,
seven,
10 people will be like,
I'm going to punch you in the fucking face.
If you ever asking me that.
Did we have two responses?
Yeah,
no,
we actually had some people like,
I'm nonbinary I'd love to talk about it,
but I'm saying usually we offend some.
Yeah,
we get hate mail every week and this,
you know,
it goes out to like,
there's well over half a million people every week.
And this question of trying to get some non binaries has led to two fucking
yeah.
Responses.
No begging.
We're like,
please bring your nonbinary as to our life.
And they were like,
hmm.
Okay.
We'll see.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll investigate.
I'll have them on.
That's deep bro.
And we'll see if it's,
yeah.
You know,
you're going to be sincere with them.
Have to be,
you have to be.
Yeah.
You can't be like,
yeah,
you fucking nerd.
Well,
if we,
if we brought them on your mom's house,
that is how will we would be a little weed shit on them a little.
I don't want to do that.
No,
I'm not hurtful.
Like you don't have hate in my heart.
Like,
yeah.
Okay.
I also make some art.
Give it up for the songs beforehand.
Oh yeah.
This guy and there's so much.
Um,
yeah,
that was a Dj Dad mouth exclusive.
There's so much,
um,
that has,
you know,
been put together for not only the live shows that you're at right now,
but the,
the studio shows and we want to actually acknowledge this is something that's
never been done before.
We teased it that we said we were going to do it on some shows.
It never happened.
But we have an opportunity tonight at this show to actually introduce you to
blue band,
the Eagle and producer of our show who goes through the emails.
He,
he assault.
He makes those clips,
you know,
every,
every fucking thing that you
panties.
Oh,
everything you hear.
Blue Band has put his little claws on.
You know he's done it.
You know,
that's blue band
blue band right there.
So how about you put your hands together for our producer?
The one and only blue band.
Let them
there is you can't do it.
You'll a mother fucker.
Yo.
Areas guys.
All right.
Blue Band.
A little band.
Um,
have you enjoyed working on this show?
Yeah,
it's been a fun job.
Yeah.
Where do you sleep at night?
In a nest.
Yeah.
There's a little bits of yarn I find along the day.
I sleep in that cause people will send to our po box.
People send like a little bird feed and they go give it to Blue Ben.
Yeah.
Thanks for that.
It's real tasty.
But you're,
you do a great job.
Thank you very much.
Is that what you pictured now?
What is it?
Bird?
The bird.
More like a different looking Jew.
Yeah.
You don't think blue band looks Jewish enough?
Are you fucking shitting me right now?
Do you want a second viewing
cheeses?
They Super Jewy maybe.
Is it the red hair?
Yeah,
it throws you off.
Yeah.
But Ari,
Ari,
Ari is Julie.
Julie.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's like offensively Jewish.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He washed on the bed,
but they're fucker.
Dad.
Has he still a Welsh on it or is it,
you know what he did?
So if you don't know,
um,
you know,
we had this bad going,
uh,
Bart and Bart burnt and I had a bet going and are you supposed to pay up?
But he was
then and then he was like,
no,
he's not paying.
And we're like,
all right,
whatever.
You fucking asshole.
And then he wrote us this long email where he was like,
I'm just happy you guys are alive and you're going to be in my voice really.
Well,
I can't mumble as much yet,
but he said that like now we're going to live longer because we lost the weight
and he's like,
I'm taking my dad to Romania this year.
I wouldn't be able to do that if he was obese.
Okay.
Why is he taking his
dad's a Romanian?
No,
he's not his hair.
His Dad was a kid in a village there before the Holocaust or some shit and he
was,
he,
it's Ari.
You understand Ra,
who's going on what?
You're going to die next week?
Like that's how he texts you every day.
And then now he's like,
my dad will see it because he's not obese and now you guys might live
that long to now that he's writing shit like that,
it's fucking weird.
My favorite is that the bat was for you guys to become declared just overweight.
Yeah.
That's the bed that he made.
I bet she overweight just to be overweight and not declared obese.
Okay.
That was his whole bed is a miracle.
Give it up for my husband for losing five.
At least.
I'm
only overweight.
It's just like the guys,
just like the guys.
You ever marry your mom?
Uh,
you know,
really
it's the most,
we actually found somebody who had the first,
we found another news story where a lady married not just her son,
but her daughter too.
That's the right response.
A woman married her son had the marriage annulled.
I didn't even know that.
You'd need to go through that,
but,
and then she's like,
oh,
Mary,
my daughter now,
so you're not going to let me marry my son or my daughter.
And that's what she did.
She married?
Yeah,
I married her son and her daughter.
Would you do that?
Would you marry your son?
Of course they come out of your vagina.
Which Mary would you marry?
Your Dad
know why
he's cool.
If I had married my mom or my dad,
definitely my dad.
My mom was cool.
Yeah,
definitely marry my dad to marry your dad over your mom fucking a hundred times.
Yeah.
Well you and your dad are like two peas in a pod buddy.
It'd be gross to kiss him and stuff,
but I still would.
He's got major dad mouth know.
It's funny because we were talking about,
um,
if I would ever date your dad,
mom,
we were laying in bed and we're like,
oh,
would you ever date my dad?
Like if I die?
And I was like,
you know what kind of,
because top dog is you in the future.
I know,
I know exactly what I'm going to be like in 30 years.
But,
but the only caveat is that I don't want to touch is pener and I don't want to
kiss his mouth because the mouth is bad.
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't blow my dad now.
He'd be so nice to you.
You don't have to,
it doesn't have to be an enthusiastic blowjob.
You have to be like,
oh,
just give him a little,
like a plop like,
well,
like I plop it in there,
he'd be done in few seconds,
it'd be great.
Yeah.
Are you done?
Yeah,
there's no way he could last long with you.
Nasty.
I'm considering this because he's an old guy though.
Do you have to factor in the age?
Is he able to get hard?
Yeah.
And don't ask me how I know,
but yeah.
Have you seen your dad with the interaction?
No,
but we've talked about it and I'm serious.
What does he say?
Because he's like,
I'm my,
my buddies,
my pals,
he take pills I hate takes by arc as a friend that hasn't it,
it takes an a direct injection into his dick.
No.
Yeah,
you can do that.
Yeah.
This guy needs it apparently.
And I didn't know you,
you injected it in scars in her eighties and he does a direct injection and I
was like,
I just asked cause it,
cause it was the topic.
I go,
oh wow.
Like you know,
is that something you're looking at it and he's like,
I got buffalo blood in me or some shit like that and some butter,
some gray.
I was like,
what?
And he's like,
no problems there buddy.
And I was like,
all right.
So,
Okay Dad.
But his balls are very hanky
now.
How do you actually,
you have seen as well I've seen his balls.
Yeah,
on a cruise two years ago.
But you were in his cabin.
In all fairness.
I was in his domain and he was laying in his boxers and he likes to wear them
paper thin.
They just,
they're just down to the tissue,
you know there are so warm.
Yeah.
They were like 30 year old boxes.
Yes.
Throwing stones because those are probably the most comfortable boxers any human
could ever wear.
And he was laying on his back and he was,
and I was sitting at the foot of the bed and both words.
She wasn't just like,
I'm here for you.
We were in there together visiting with my,
it's a vacation and you're like,
Hey dad,
what are you doing?
You know,
like hanging out.
And so I'm sitting in the chair and he's whatever on the bed and he flips over
and the blankets like kicked off of him and he swings his leg.
Yeah,
I Cambo and his nuts.
Just poop.
And I did the thing that probably most of you would do,
it's like your wife's in the room and you see your dad.
I go,
Hey dad,
can you cover your balls real quick?
Right.
Not because,
I mean I wouldn't do,
but it's like,
it's,
it's your daughter in law,
but I've seen so many balls.
It doesn't matter what his reaction was.
He goes,
ah,
come on,
autonomy
sound like your mother.
And I'm like,
what are you talking about man?
Like I'm not telling you like don't eat that me saying
will you cover your balls right now?
And he insisted on not and he's like,
yeah,
but being a baby.
But I feel like that's such a dad thing because my dad too,
I remember in the 80s would wear those short shorts,
like new magical Johnson would.
Where are those
magic Johnson
and dude,
you guest hosting sports center is my dream.
Like that would be,
they're going to call any minute now.
Amazing thing.
Magical Johnson.
So,
but you know what I'm talking magical throws the ball.
So I remember they would wear those short shorts in the 80s and my dad used to
wear those and I remember he would sit with,
you know how guys crossed their legs one leg over and I'm,
his knots would pop out all the time.
I feel like that's what dads do.
They just show you their balls.
Well,
at a certain point.
So I mean like I understand you do it to Ellis all the time.
I don't go like,
Hey,
look at my,
Oh yeah,
no,
but you walk around in your boxers.
Yeah,
of course.
I'm at home.
I don't give a shit.
Right.
That's it.
That's what I'm saying.
That's a good dad thing.
That thing you're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Get used to it.
They're my balls.
Yeah.
My,
my dad's though.
You're right.
I mean,
I think it's partly with age too,
but I've seen him fucking like I've come into his bedroom where he just got out
of the shower and he's like,
hey buddy walks by and I see him like walk past me,
throw his towel down,
grab underwear,
and as he bends over to put them on,
I'm like,
oh my God,
God.
Like it looks like a wild hog.
If you ever seen yes.
Here.
Yes.
Sorry.
They're like big those giant garlic cloves.
Yeah,
like real ball bus at the end.
And it's weird to be like,
that's where I came from.
That's my first house.
It was right there.
Yep.
Yeah.
Yes.
And then your dad just in your mind.
No,
I remember the story.
I remember.
Yeah,
my buddy.
So
you think that's his finishing line by
your mom?
What do you think he says?
I don't,
I don't know.
We can change topics now and that's,
it actually is probably something like that.
Yeah.
What do you think your dad's is Gerald
got it gets up real quick.
You know how he gets up after a meal super fast.
I'm done.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's definitely,
yeah,
so he probably like,
no,
my mom is,
my mind has actually confirmed that she goes there with you.
The father is like Mia because,
because he's been,
he's like,
I'm gonna take a shower,
my bay play.
He gets up immediately.
No,
we do it.
And then you say get out.
Yeah,
get out as my closing line and I recommend it.
It's a fun thing to do.
Try it with your spouse or girlfriend or whatever.
Right.
If you're the girl,
that was even better.
Imagine what a mind fuck you would do to most guys if like,
he's like,
oh,
and then you go get out and he's like,
I think I'm in love.
You're like fucking like you dude.
But then,
but guys would love that.
Do it to a guy you really like and not come back.
I love it.
Oh my God,
please.
I would have been hooked immediately on that
attitude problem,
but just like the,
you came over
and we did it and I basically was like,
get the fuck out of here.
And then you're like,
can I come over tomorrow?
Can I see you again,
girl.
What's your number girl?
You're in my head.
He's all like the gays.
You were telling like that with me.
Like I was not like,
girl,
you're in my heart for real.
Oh
yes,
no,
I was like,
anyways,
you are not.
You are,
you just loved me.
What?
Yeah,
that's cause I was mean to you.
I was a little dismissive.
I was cold.
But you know why?
Because my heart had been broken.
I was,
I was mending a broken heart and I wasn't no fucking dude.
I don't want to get married.
I don't want no kids.
Fuck this.
And then you are like,
you just loved it.
But it was perfect because the girl I dated before you was a total Dalmatian,
so I was,
well,
you've been saying that in private a Dalmatian.
Yeah.
That's good.
We haven't had on the show yet.
I know they're super,
yeah.
Dopey.
Right?
Like a Maltese or a,
yeah.
Malteses are dumber.
Hi.
Like Schnitzel.
Yeah.
But anyway,
so you were dating a Dalmatian
and I love what you told me about this the other day we've been talking about,
no,
she used to like as a like as a treat.
Like it was supposed to be exciting.
She had straight hair.
Right?
Like,
like,
like Christina has straight hair but like on black knight curls but like
childlike curls were
and she'd be like,
I curled it and she's like,
do you like it?
I'll be like,
you looked like Shirley temple right now.
Like do I like it?
No,
I don't want to fucking eight year old.
What are you talking about?
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like it was like a,
it was a childlike looking.
She's like,
I did it in front of you.
I'd be like,
you can undo
it for me too,
cause I don't like it at all.
Brush that shit out.
The worst is I had to pretend I'd be like,
oh you did the fucking curls again.
That's awesome.
Like
she would do like those tendrils,
right?
Yeah.
Like southern bell.
That's a fucking great.
But like it was like an attempt to do like that Farrah Fawcett seventies look.
Yep.
Yep,
You're all curls.
Yeah.
But it wasn't,
it was just like,
I'm a good girl right now.
Like it did she put bows in it too?
She was almost there.
Yeah.
What do you get your dog back from the groomer.
And you're like,
especially when they do it to your mail and you're like,
do you think he wants that bone?
They do it to fifa all the time.
I'm like,
quick queer.
And I'm like,
fucking non-binary stopped doing that.
He hasn't chosen his gender yet.
Wow.
Him Ask him his pro bono as as it.
It's Zimmer Pronouns Jesus.
That's
tendrils.
And so
pretend like you,
isn't that funny when you're dating somebody,
you just,
you have to let some of the small stuff slide.
If you're not marrying a person,
you know,
we're in that,
I'm trying to think.
I told you,
you guys,
you've heard this one,
but I had a guy I was dating when I worked at Starbucks and the summer of 19,
whatever,
and he had,
this guy was,
he was a sweet guy.
He still lived at home.
He was like 25 [inaudible] stupid spells
and um,
he got a tattoo of the band rocket from the crypt
because you can't get into a mass white shit to me right now.
Oh,
okay.
Blackie
real cool name to give me whatever.
I don't,
I couldn't think of the word that was more politically correct.
Right.
So he had a rocket from the crypt tattoo so that he could get into all their
shows for free.
That's so fucking lame.
I know.
I was like all your other kind of alluded to
me about that lame ass bullshit.
And then I looked it up and then I found out I read an article.
Yeah.
So all they're die hard fans did that.
And then I guess they went away for awhile and then they had a comeback tour,
but the comeback tours like your die hard fans.
So they all had that tattoo.
And they were like,
yeah,
that,
that's no good anymore.
We're not doing
pause.
So all these people that got it tattooed,
he could not benefit from it anymore.
That's terrible.
Yeah.
That's like when I was on road rules and we all got tattoos and then shut up.
I have a tea,
I have a drum.
It's so embarrassing.
It's terrible.
It's fucking dog shit.
But one of the guys,
one of the guys on on my show got a tattoo of the road rule symbol on ankle.
I know he regrets it.
Now he's got like a family and kids.
Did he change it to something else?
No,
it's still you can do.
You should tell him that's an option.
You can change it.
I know he could make a flower.
Do anything.
Anything else?
Yeah,
we haven't done a proper show.
Open one,
right?
So first of all,
this is the late show
out of your minds.
Thank you for coming out.
As always,
here's a clip to get us started and the opening of our show.
Here we go.
Just drizzle in some of the included moist water based lubricant.
Slide yourself in and you're ready to drill her like an oil rig.
Well,
welcome to your mom's house.
That's my favorite.
It's
always like two guys in the band that catch each other.
No,
I feel anything that's such a white guy thing that's an old white guy.
Really Black.
He tells about it.
Blackie,
Jesus,
I don't know has past my bedtime.
I'm usually asleep by now.
You actually really are pushing every night.
He 89
yeah.
I have to turn the TV volume down now.
Well like,
yeah,
it's too loud.
I can't sleep.
He used to always be like,
turn the TV on,
watch something,
watch something.
And I'd be like,
all right,
this lab,
that's how fucking close your eyes.
This is what you sound like.
And you tend to
see,
they think it's you.
Why do I talk like a homeless person with no,
no,
no.
Why do you talk like that?
And I don't know.
I asked them.
Mary mom.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's,
that's dumb.
That's hair.
Do you like that one juice?
Why
is he saying Jews?
I don't understand.
He's improvising.
So it's a,
it's a scene where a lady actor squirting into a guy's face and it's like
showering.
So he goes to juice.
He's improvising but a squirt considered juice.
No,
it's not.
But imagine you're in the moment.
Say something.
Yeah,
he could've,
he could've said anything like coffee,
whatever.
He said.
Juice.
That is such a neat story.
You're welcome
to bring this up because I am,
my friend came over last night and he's single and he's on Tinder,
which is not just a fuck site anymore apparently.
It's not just for fuck boys.
We've missed that boat completely.
Totally.
Do you know that when Tom and I started seeing each other,
there was Friendster and myspace.
It's true.
Everyone on my space was the shit.
Like you need to update your profile
and like putting music on there and everyone was so excited and that became
[inaudible] planned.
How did that,
that transition was,
I feel like that was quick.
My space was the like if you were a comic,
you plug your dates on there.
It was the thing and Dane Cook fucking hard at that.
Started that whole thing,
man.
And he would like,
he would email every single person back that emailed it and we're talking not
like a hundred emails,
like it would thousands would pouring millions.
He was the first person to have like right.
But I'm saying he was engaging everybody and then I feel like it was like one
day you were just like,
hey my space and they're like you fucking piece of shit.
And like they would talk to you like you were bleeding out of your neck.
That's how Friendster was to remember.
I don't remember what Friendster was precursor to my space and it was even,
it was lamer though.
You could only put like pictures of yourself.
There was nothing shiny or razzle dazzle.
It was just like here's me.
People could like were you on Friendster?
Of course.
2004 dude.
Wow,
Super Rad.
But I was thinking,
what about Lincoln done?
Where are you on
Linkedin?
Fuck Lincoln.
Then clap if you're on Lincoln.
Some people
down,
I get offers.
I declined.
What I was thinking how great it would be if you are on Tinder and what your
profile would be.
Cause I know if you were single you'd be so fucking lost in this digital
wasteland.
What you're talking about.
Cause you're retarded.
Like you wouldn't know
like little stuff like okay.
Okay.
Cause we learned last night that when you swipe,
okay,
so the first picture that you see somebody that's the lead photo,
that's the most important photo.
That's,
that's your a game bro.
So like don't put a fucking picture with you and your friend.
Cause now it's confusing.
Yeah.
Why would you fucking,
cause we were going through our friends and like every like third girl,
there was two girls in the picture.
We're like,
well what's bitch isn't man,
which one of them's a sluttier one.
We were trying to hook him up last night.
And like some of the girls,
like their lead thing was like,
no hookups were like fucking Xq.
Yeah.
So excited though.
This whole world of hooking up.
So anyway,
okay.
So I was like,
I wonder what Toms would be.
Here's your lead photo.
I know it.
Dick and balls.
What do you mean?
And you're like,
suck my stuff.
Am I right?
You guys know him.
Yeah.
It'd be like,
you guys want to suck this?
No,
because I know that that wouldn't lead to it getting sucked.
So while I chair,
well,
what's your lead photo be thinking about that photo.
All right,
here's my take photo to like try to get,
you know,
Tinder swiped right.
And so here we go.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Wow.
No,
I think you have to like down,
you can't do like this.
Some people have that obnoxious photo.
You have to kind of downplay it a little bit.
What people overshoot because people put photos that like are too flattering.
You know?
Let's start with a headshot,
like a professional
Robin von Swank.
You know,
I would hold the camera down here so that like,
like double chins or accentuated and then if you meet me,
be like,
that's even better than I thought.
That's what I would do.
No bitch is going to click on you.
Fucking double Chins.
Maybe.
Maybe some sad ones that are wellness.
Oh good.
You're a genius.
Yeah.
I'm not looking for a serious thing.
Stupid.
We did see that some people put like,
like,
you know some people do real serious shit like,
yeah man,
tell I'm intellectual.
Some girl had the fucking,
some girl had her list.
She was like,
it must be muscular.
This habit must have a certain income.
If you don't,
then go ahead and swipe it.
I was like,
this bitch,
I hope you get a virus.
Like I,
I hope your profile gets a virus.
I'm serious.
It's Patti Stanger would say that it's unreasonable.
Do the lists,
the list is stupid.
No,
you shouldn't have like you have to meet every single one.
It's a dumb way to meet somebody.
There was the one kid though,
he had the funny set.
Sometimes I think the funny ones are the way to go.
Right?
Because women always say humor,
but not really because you're the guy with the sense of,
you know what I mean?
No,
I'm just saying a lot of women can't handle what is,
I love him.
You know that he's my heart.
I would lay down my life for this motherfucker,
but she's always saying
people like you like,
but it's little shit.
Like,
we're finished banging and then he literally does roll over and go
get out.
You would find that charming if you were with me?
Yes.
Would it wouldn't be like,
oh,
like just may you be like,
get out of here bitch.
That wasn't only like that,
that,
but it's funny.
And then he was farting.
We made sweet love.
And then two minutes later you farted in the bed and,
but then he goes,
why don't you give me credit?
I was like,
for what?
He goes,
I've been holding them in all night.
That's real life stuff.
We're going to act like I'm the only dude that does that.
No,
you do it too.
And you also want credit.
You want,
I'm not asking
you to fucking like be like,
why?
Like buy me a gift.
But how about you go,
wow,
that's really,
uh,
you weren't credit for holding in a fart while we're doing it.
That doesn't,
that's not,
we'll do that all the time.
Right.
But they don't want credits.
Again,
it's a given.
I'm the only one brave enough to speak up for this
community.
But then my favorite part.
So you farted and then I looked over,
we were just,
we were just talking about life or whatnot.
And you're picking your toes
and then he ripped off a Tony.
Yeah.
Huh.
And then did one of these
over the floor.
Right.
So as not to get it in the bed,
which I do appreciate.
That's all I'm asking for it.
Thank you.
And you're welcome.
So wait,
but that's the guy with a sense of humor that's on the,
go ahead.
There was the,
the kid with the funny profile that was,
sorry.
Go.
Yeah.
Funny.
I like that one picture of him,
he was 18,
he wearing sunglasses.
He has a cigarette hanging out of his mouth and he has a rifle and he's like,
the butt of it is in his hip.
And he's like,
and in his profile was,
um,
what's the difference between Jelly and jam?
And then it said,
I can't Jelly a dick in your ass.
That's good.
That's a funny kid.
You wouldn't swipe right on that and know why not.
He's funny you like,
I think that's a funny kid.
Right?
Funny guys.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
And if he were,
what did your critique to that kid?
What's wrong with that?
That's a funny approach,
Babe.
Babe,
what?
No,
you,
I would encourage that kid every day.
If I knew him,
I'd be like,
step it up dude.
Push it
harder.
Like,
yeah,
I would be so bad at this profile would be a fucking real with your bio line.
Be fucking I do it.
I don't know.
Fucking dude.
And I would swipe.
I'd be like,
this chick is cool.
That would interest me.
Here's what I would do.
Real talk.
I'd be very honest and direct.
I'd be like,
I don't have any fucking hobbies because I work and I have a kid and I like to
watch a lot of TV.
Do you like to sleep a lot?
I like to sleep.
I like to eat.
I don't like doing stuff
well cause I fucking don't.
The fact that we have a kid and makes us do stuff all the time and that's like,
it's a lot.
No.
But look,
if,
if you're on this,
it means that you're newly single,
so you'd be a little more excited than that.
I know you'd be bad,
but here's the thing,
when I was single,
when you and I started dating,
I kept it 100 like that,
cause you call me the first time to ask for a date and you're like,
Hey,
do you want to go hiking?
And I was like,
fuck no,
that's true.
That's true.
Sorry I to go on a hike because it was like a very la,
it's a nice thing to do.
I know.
And Anyway,
I hung up and that's the thing is I didn't hike.
You know,
it wasn't like I was just like,
oh that's a cool guy,
la date.
Like do you want to go on a hike?
And then you see them all hiking,
look good looking people.
So I asked her like,
I'll pretend to be that guy.
And she was like,
no,
I don't want to like that.
But I didn't,
I didn't put it together that you were asking me out on a date until I hung up.
And then I felt really bad.
I was like,
oh my God,
I think Tom Segura I just tried to ask me on a day and I fucked it all up dude.
So then like I forget how I think I told my friend to tell you I liked you or
something stupid.
And then we ended up going to a star in sixth grade.
I go,
I just asked her how he was like,
Oh okay.
Yeah,
cause I don't know how to date.
Like I don't know how to do it.
I call you and you're like,
the funny thing is though,
I asked,
I asked her out on a date,
I asked her to marry your mom.
I asked her out on a date to go on a hike and she said no.
And then I asked her out again and she goes,
yeah,
how about I'll pick the place I know a bar where you can still smoke.
And that's where we ended up going.
So we went from hiking to a bar.
You can still smoke
now.
I to God,
we should bring this guy.
Fuck yeah,
dude,
we're so stoked for this.
One of the all time hall of fame,
greatest guests we've ever had.
We'll get it is back here with us and we could not be happier to have him.
Uh,
you know
him.
You love him.
Please give a warm round of applause to the one and only Yoshi.
Everybody.
Yeah.
All right.
I was told me it's going to be one minute.
I've been wearing that thing.
What happened?
Our,
oh my God.
Oh,
that was our pup play.
Mom.
Make a terrible rapist.
Alright.
Um,
what did you think of the mask?
It's great meeting Taiwan.
Um,
now do you know what that's for?
No.
Well,
BDSM or something?
yeah,
yes,
it's a pup play thing,
but it's not sexual.
It's,
I forgot there were so cold.
I was just going to go out and run around and uh,
maybe a by a black person,
but um,
but this is orange county.
You don't have one.
All right.
Ah,
yeah.
By the way,
congratulation all,
most of the people in this room,
uh,
for the way people,
president Trump,
white men are back.
Look at Tommy,
you lose weight.
You look great guys.
We're fucking back.
All right.
We're back.
I'm so happy.
I'm so happy to be back on top.
It was a rough fucking eight years.
Wow.
All the blackies were doing their thing.
Now it's back to us.
Could just making America great.
But you don't cut.
A lot of people surprise when Trump won.
Yeah.
A lot of the,
a politician,
analysts and people were wrong.
There's one industry predicted this last three terms,
four terms.
It's pornography.
Pornography predicted the winners.
Last jury presidents.
Wait,
who in pornography?
No,
no.
I'm a little before Obama won.
Yeah.
The most popular porn at the place I used to work.
The boy angel was interracial porn.
America was ready for black man.
Right in the White House.
Right.
Now some of you saying yourself.
How did pornography predict Bush?
Uh,
late nineties.
the most popular point at that time is torture porn.
Wow.
You know,
you grab a girl's hair and put it in the toilet,
not a boarding America was ready for it.
Right,
right.
So
I know what you're saying.
Well,
what kind of porn was so popular that predict president Trump?
Yeah.
Two words for you.
Incest Porn?
No,
the people in pornography called taboo relation,
but you know what it is right?
I want to fuck Umami or step brother this and that.
Right.
If you listen to Trump,
when you talk about your bunker Trump so many times he said,
if she wasn't my daughter,
I would date her.
That was that same way into my head.
Come Outta my other here.
What he's saying is I want to fuck my daughter.
That's what I'm hearing.
Yeah.
And that's the normal ear and down into my balls.
I like that.
Yeah,
that was nice.
it was good.
I have come all over my face now.
It's great to be back.
So good to see you do.
Fans are the best.
Nicest people.
There's a lot of 40 people
business,
but um,
Christina,
Tom,
they're always great offstage and uh,
you know,
she's always concerned about me.
They get therapy and things like that.
It's not going to happen.
But um,
if I can beat you up,
I can't get hard.
But
you bought,
we also are always asking because you've been doing some of the medical testing.
Yeah.
Have you been doing it lately?
Um,
I'm,
I'm currently for a couple of them.
I'm getting ready to do another one within a week or so.
And uh,
cirrhosis.
And what was the other one?
Um,
hepatitis B or something.
I Dunno.
Um,
sometime when I don't qualify for studies,
I am a recruiter.
So like I,
if I don't have a,
um,
lady problem,
I look at,
you know,
go around the mall and look for someone.
Well,
what do you mean?
What does that mean?
So like there'll be like a medical test,
but it will be only for women only for winning.
So you'll just walk up to and be like,
hey,
it was really awkward because recently,
recently there was a study,
for some reason they were looking for people with a surgical co and their body
two inches or longer.
So,
um,
I was at the mall recently,
why?
I went the morning hot dog and like,
um,
because I didn't qualify,
I was low on cash.
Then I see this group of teenage girls,
one of them kinda got up kind of Pinto.
We're trying to get something.
And I noticed she had a cut in a,
you know,
buy this has cheek right near there.
Right.
This is,
this is going and that like,
I wasn't really thinking,
excuse me.
Halloween's you'll cut in your back,
whatever.
Right.
God dammit.
They all gave me this really look like,
oh no,
this is about it.
So one of them rent to security
and I just turned around,
ran out like remember this,
he tagged you run.
I haven't been because he was,
I don't know if it was awkward.
They did it.
They have a really weird energy.
So don't you hear how much worse it sounds right now or yeah.
Now,
but I would thought was helping her
do,
man,
he gave me this really low.
We're look.
Yeah.
And then one went to a security guard.
And um,
do you remember the
scene from taxi driver when uh,
dineros caregiver Trevis Beko trying to kill,
send the parenting and just talking to the secret service and like,
he's just going to run out.
That's what I fucking dead.
I ran the fuck on it there because you know,
in past I've been accused of things that's not true.
Yeah.
Huh?
How old,
how old were they,
would you guess?
I don't know.
15 to 18
I wasn't sure.
How long has that scar on you?
I to go,
but it was $200 he find,
found the person and another 200 if she finished the study.
So that's 400
wow.
That's worth it.
So great.
Am I in that post office?
$200 sorry.
She gets Thomas.
Does she get to do this study?
400 if she does the whole thing,
I get 400 think she gets like 2,500 Oh my God.
Yeah.
I'm giving
how many teenage girls make 2,540 days.
That a few but not a lot.
Yeah.
Okay.
And that's a tricky question.
It depends on the color of the skin.
All right.
Um,
funny in Texas.
All right.
Oh,
okay.
Do you guys ever get in trouble because I'm on your show.
I did worry about that some time.
I'm now,
our audience is the best.
They don't.
Yeah.
There's no offended.
Yeah,
no,
you guys don't give a shit.
Honestly,
I couldn't imagine a podcast show on Sunday two shows.
500 people bananas.
This is so funny.
This is a show we were talking to like our manager or something like this is a
show about shitting.
Yeah.
Coming,
come and shit.
And it's the best.
I'm perfect void.
Yeah,
we all are.
So that opening clip was about this new product that we can't show them a
obviously,
but they can hear it.
And I want to know if you have ever experimented with something like this.
You'll see it on the screen here.
Okay.
No,
the screen in front of me.
Oh sorry.
I was confused.
Asian eyes,
what can I say?
These realistic,
deep throat simulators are available in two varieties including blonde and
Brunette to fulfill all your fantasies.
So it's basically the severed head of a woman.
You know what it looks like it was something like that.
No,
but um,
those Barbie heads,
he used to put makeup on when you're a little girl in the 80s and the,
except it's got a map.
And then like the,
I like this way and the mouth is like,
but only way I could use that.
I gotta Punch one that I first had a
right,
sure.
That the severed head with the mouth hole that you can
fuck
just the bum member of the side cut off
this hole in the vagina.
The head thing is definitely kind of creepy eyes,
corpse eyes,
just like it.
It's not the same thing.
But when I,
when I moved to your first,
you know what really freaked me out,
cause we never seen this thing in Japan is um,
I don't know if they still have it has a horse's head with a s just a stick.
You right.
Yes.
The fuck he said,
what kind of country is this?
Because where's the rest of the fucking body?
You know?
And my mom said this is a poor country.
They can't put the whole damn thing.
Yeah.
But that really freaked me out because they didn't really freak you out.
Said is it,
am I the only one?
It looks really nice.
It's a stick with a fucking the head.
Yeah.
You're supposed to pretend to ride the horse.
Oh yeah.
Well,
this whole actually fucked the mouth.
There's different similar idea though.
They have hair.
You can style
stretchy mouth about anyone
throat that will feel as good,
if not better than the real thing.
That's a good point there.
And here's the best part.
Unlike some girls who don't know how to give head or aren't in the mood,
these realistic beauties know how to Suck Dick and will never say no.
This bitch never says no because she's like,
she never says anything.
That's right.
That's the dream.
I kind of much prefer if they're kind of close to each other like Siamese twin
because have you ever seen the these twin like,
uh,
happy?
I've seen one where one is really hot,
but other ones ugly.
I've seen one.
It was just like,
I noticed the hot one,
so like,
okay,
so the hot ones giving the guy a blow job and other ones maybe reading a book
with that,
you know,
flipping the book like this,
you know what I mean?
Is it just okay?
Just me.
All right.
Um
Huh.
In addition to realistic hair.
Each one comes with lipstick for an even more lifelike experience.
Yeah,
I liked it.
It feels like real life.
What about the cleanup on the head?
Oh,
that's the next clip.
you'll find on the bottom of the neck there's a drain hole.
Flusher
drain.
They say they call it the flush your debris.
Debris.
I don't know why it's called debris that could own clam chowder mouth.
You know I'm calling about,
um,
I'm from Seattle,
so I'm
salty.
I made a fan of flesh,
which mimics the look and feel of real.
He's like,
it's stretchy,
soft and durable.
You can be as rough as you like or practice essential throat fucking so that
you're a better letter for your girlfriend or wife or your girlfriend or wife.
That's why I got one
though.
You'd lab might be a deal breaker if you file your boyfriend's head that he's
been fucking
really,
I don't know if I can continue.
Oh,
but it's got the drain plug.
What do you think those Chinese people making dose in Beijing at the warehouse?
You know,
they're like eight year old Slade neighbors.
Making it for are
now.
You can't bind them because fucking Trump's going to,
you know,
alright,
you ruined this whole industry.
We got to make them here in America.
Tell us about this story.
Can I play a one of your old yeah,
I fucked the girl with no arms and one leg.
Yes I did.
Um,
I'm trying to,
I can't remember the Buddha.
Remember.
I can't,
that would be my story.
I would open while you guys were here.
A fucking crazy story,
Tommy.
I mean,
we're talking about,
I know you've been with a lot of women,
no fucking no arms and one leg and you're like,
was that fucking Austin or I,
I'm have girls with missing limb,
um,
here and there
and Eastern Europe and uh,
I'm not,
I'm not prejudice against them.
You shouldn't be.
But I thought it would,
I didn't know it was like,
you're like,
ah,
fucking happens all the time.
I didn't know it was one of those.
Wait,
does she have a leg?
I thought she didn't have any,
I can't remember.
I've had situation where I went to down on a girl.
Yeah.
And it
does limit us.
All right.
Um,
and I remember going down like,
oh,
because of the taste,
I remember like,
she changed her hair,
so she didn't,
she didn't look that way I to remember three,
four years ago.
But going down to her and it's like a fingerprint.
Everyone have a specific flavor to them and you don't like wine connoisseur but
me,
I just,
you know,
there's like a fingerprints,
whatever flavor.
So you were like,
I remember you,
I don't remember her feet by like Sarah
really because women change their hair,
whatever,
like divert to sit there,
right?
Yeah.
Like they're evil,
but the taste I remember.
Yeah,
I remember you.
And you're a member of the amputees taste is what you're saying.
Or because there's been more than one,
but uh,
it's always eastern Europe and um,
have a good attitude.
They always have a better attitude.
Fucking better.
Have a good attitude.
Yeah.
To,
if you had an
amputee,
hooker,
limbless bad addict,
you shut up.
I don't know if I had to put a telephone book and aside because the missing
limb,
I don't,
I'm trying to remember how that
so funny.
All right.
So,
um,
wait,
so we were talking about,
because you know,
we've been together since,
since,
uh,
online dating took off.
Do you do online anything,
like any Tinder profiles,
anything like that?
No,
never.
but no,
I'm kind of old fat.
No,
because you're not old fashioned technology wise.
There's nothing.
I've only got one prostitute and states when I was under age kid,
like this is like I told you this before,
1985,
summer of 85,
I got kicked out of Washington state.
I moved to Long Beach and there was this,
yeah,
it's great.
I mean it's nice now.
It wasn't back in those days,
let's be honest.
But um,
it's nice now,
but,
um,
black girl.
But other than that,
all the hookers spending like Canada,
Mexico and Europe,
Brazil,
I don't think I've ever,
it's weird where I grew up in Japan,
uh,
prostitution,
it's like normal par,
you know,
it's um,
we have a big hangup.
Well because it's just a job to rest of the world.
But I'm like,
I just got back from Europe.
Remember that illegal magazine when I was talking to you guys?
Yeah.
They have a secondary business called six salons where we have a van,
uh,
parking in a neighborhood in Denmark.
And a prostitute will take their John into a van,
fuck them.
And to have a chair,
if you know,
if you want to get a blowjob,
it's right there.
They have a knee pads so they don't hurt themselves.
There's comm games.
Um,
so,
so we're,
we're protecting these women because,
um,
because a lot of the prostitutes,
street hookers,
they have a high percent of getting murdered.
So we were providing a safe place to clean their business.
Um,
I know,
I know some people think is funny,
but last few years my big way,
but I think six worksheets be protected all forms cause otherwise,
thanks again.
Brutalized and hooked on drugs and yeah,
and we should just legalize because ladies,
put yourself in a situation where maybe you didn't have a good luck and you're
desperate.
And this is one of the few things available to take care of your family.
Uh,
last thing you need is you cops harassing you and the crazy customers.
I'm,
I'm all for protecting these women,
you know?
Well,
go really quiet here.
Okay.
Anyway,
so wait,
do you think you'd be a good,
you'd be a good hoe though.
If you were a prostitute,
what do you think you'd be a good prostitute?
No,
look at me,
but I mean,
what would your attitude be like?
Like show me,
show me what it means.
Me being processed.
Yes,
he knows so much.
Let's just role play for a second.
No.
Have you ever considered it?
All right,
so how much experience have you ever considered being a male?
I'm more customer.
I mean,
I buy food from restaurant.
That's not me.
I'm going to be a good chef.
I think you'd be like,
let's just try it for a second.
It's like an actress becomes director.
Here's the closest thing I've ever done.
When I used to work in tableau video in downtown Seattle,
we have,
you know,
a lot of young people don't know,
but they used to have these booths in the back where guys go in,
put a quarter on what you should it.
Right?
Yeah.
Just go ahead it too.
So,
so taboo BDO,
I used to work there and we used to get this handicap guy,
he's in one of this mechanical wheelchair,
right?
So he goes in,
so you know,
cause disability.
So I got to open the door,
pull him in there.
He got a little fucking whiny.
Like Ooh,
could you unzip my zipper,
whatever.
Like oh
fuck.
But I don't want to be prejudice against handicap people.
Right,
right.
It's not like,
oh get it down.
So I don't know my handicapped people,
but really long zipper.
But anyway,
I pull it down,
pull his pants down.
I don't want look and put a quarter and a close the door.
Right.
And,
and then,
uh,
I don't know,
15,
20 minutes later or something,
some customers say,
hey,
I need your help,
whatever.
So I have to go in,
I put a glove on,
you know what I mean?
Their customer,
they're people too.
You know what handicapped people deserve to have orgasms.
Yeah,
sure.
They deserve it.
Yeah.
So like fuck,
I don't want to,
you know,
because all the coworkers and I'm the rookie new kid,
so I have to do all the work.
So,
um,
so I go in,
it's a fucking mess.
Right?
So cool.
Wait,
wait.
He can't touch his,
could you help me and night and he's,
you know,
he's doing his business.
I call it,
I don't want to look at it as buck.
I'm not a Weirdo.
So,
um,
he can touch it though.
I guess you could touch it,
but you know,
his hands are on spot up lights like this.
Right.
No matter what.
I didn't do that.
Jesus dead.
All right.
Um,
so,
um,
yeah,
you tried to do the Zipper,
which a fucking crap fingers.
Right?
So,
um,
so I don't know,
somehow he,
your guy wins at hand.
One on one arm is shorter than the other one,
you know,
uh,
look like fenders,
roof.
So anyway,
he does his business.
It's all weird.
Right?
I can't,
I can't just kicked out,
get the fuck out of equip or I can't do that.
So,
so I put a glove,
put it on sticky.
They like that,
like,
you know,
funny.
And finally I put find it,
I'm putting him from the front door and his mechanic is leaving.
He goes,
thanks a lot.
Faggot.
And he just leave like that.
That's so rude.
1999.
Seattle.
That's a true story.
All right.
So
that's what he used to be able to call people faggots.
That's the real me part of that story.
Right?
It's just like the gays.
No.
So you put his dick away for him.
You kind of skipped over that part a little bit.
Um,
I don't know.
How did I do it?
How did it pulled up the underwear that you helped them out?
Right.
You know,
pivot the digging that hole like that and then uh,
you know,
put it,
hold on.
What's a fucking mess?
Boy,
he come every,
I mean I've got a hand at the end to decrypt those.
Have a lot of com.
Yeah.
So when we got,
okay,
so we have this or cleaning up the calm on the crippled guy.
Yeah,
that's your job.
Okay.
All right.
Or
you got to fuck the lady's fake head.
That's your only sexual outlet.
And every time you go out on a first date with a girl,
you have to be like,
my name's Tom and hear Susan and you gotta
you gotta bring her out to dinner.
So it's either clean up the crippled guys stories,
your life,
my life.
You clean up the cripple,
you have to put his,
but then I'm free to have a sexual life.
But that is your job bro.
You do that fucking thing.
I can go on dates and I always have to bring out the severed blowjob ahead and
introduce her to people on a first day immediately.
Immediately.
And you have to show the features,
the Nice,
let's do you know what type of red flag individual would be cool with that?
Like not that like,
cause I said women would be like,
yeah,
that's cool yard.
But if you were like,
nice to meet you,
what should we get to eat?
Hold on though.
One second.
And then you live the debris comes out of the bottom of the neck and if it comes
with realistic lipstick and you have to show her yeah,
you put lipstick on and then open.
I'd be it.
Wait,
you look put a makeup on,
Huh?
Yeah.
Cause it's one of the features.
So,
well there you go.
There's your choices for life.
Go ahead.
I think I'd be,
I'd be mopping up some Jizz on some wheelchairs.
I think it what I was doing.
Yeah.
It doesn't ruin your life as much,
isn't that what you would do?
Yeah,
of course.
I mean it's not a cool job.
I mean how many,
it's 40 hours a week of cleaning.
Come off of guys in wheelchairs and putting their penis is back in their pants.
It's not a fun job.
But then you get the rest of your free time.
You might be actually turned on by it.
You don't even know it's true.
You don't know.
Maybe that'd be like that.
Maybe that's your secret.
We all,
you know I've had,
I think,
I know,
I don't think you'd think some with Christina.
I do think I do.
Yeah,
I've heard it enough in the business.
Like some women do like the smells permit and it does what?
Collect.
There's 500 people in here,
half to be a woman that you meet me.
There's not a one girl and there's probably one normal cheese,
but there's also,
there's also a number of them shaking their heads right now.
Let's,
uh,
let's get out of just for a moment and we have a master of accents submission
that I would like to play for you.
And um,
you can tell me if you can decipher what this human being is saying.
Here we go.
[inaudible]
what?
No,
that's not even right.
Give me an accent.
Where is it?
Master sense.
Is this a better one?
[inaudible]
that's fucking horrific.
That's what I heard.
Hold on.
How about this one here?
Well,
if you're watching on the Sally and yet,
and it was the 40 stuff a minute and you've still got until my first goal,
would you leave and just make it blue?
You wouldn't see what you see.
People leave and come on back.
Holly Pizza boxes and the main stunned in it.
I just think where's the club gone
English right there.
I saw Jamaican.
No,
you're definitely last.
Restless.
What are you hearing?
Nobody said,
here's what we've discovered so far.
I'm master of as accents Jello.
It can sound.
So like how many people know what that guy was saying?
Do any of you know?
He might know Scott.
Is it Scottish?
Yes,
you're correct.
Let's also
three people claim to know what the fuck's going on and how did he do that?
How did he do that?
I don't know man.
I don't know how the fuck you did that.
Do you have like British parents?
Did you study over there?
Live over there.
Weird talk now.
So here's what he actually saw the clip.
He says what you're watching on the Sally and he says if you were watching on
the tele and your house and it was the 42nd minute and you're still going for
that first goal,
would you leave and just make a brew?
You wouldn't.
Oh right.
It was the 47 minute and you've still going through our first goal.
Would you leave?
You just make up do you wouldn't
now.
Wow.
Right now that I say it,
you're like the fucking matrix.
This is crazy.
And then he says,
but you see people leaving and coming back with pizza boxes in the main stand.
I just think where's the club gone?
But you see if he fully even [inaudible] pizza boxes in the main stand on it,
Wow.
That makes sense.
Master of accents now.
Wow.
Did you,
were you able to put that together at all?
Sound like Mark Warburg to me.
I have terrible years.
That sounded like Mark Walberg too.
Yeah.
I don't know why.
Well,
I want to be in your head so badly.
I want to watch every mark Wahlberg movie with you.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
we have,
we decided we'd,
since we knew you were going to be a guest,
we would pull some master of accents more in your wheelhouse.
So
wait,
what does that mean?
Well,
I'll tell you what it means.
Um,
we found some Asians
in English reading and English,
but they have accents.
And I want to know if you can tell,
oh,
what,
what country,
what they're saying even.
Oh,
I think these are Japanese women,
I think.
Yeah.
So this is,
um,
are they crying?
That's Japanese.
Alright.
That was pretty funny.
Put together.
You tell me if you just listen.
Okay.
Tell me if you can understand what they're saying.
Here we go.
Okay.
I cook good.
Good night.
I will be shocked if that's not a Japanese girl.
Yeah,
it's just,
yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
Do you know what she said?
No,
but um,
you mean to tell you something about cook?
Yes.
She says I cook an egg roll in my butthole.
Okay.
Why did you have to bring my mother into this conversation?
Tommy?
Now very rude
is from four Chan.
This is,
uh,
people were writing to these women as they're recording,
um,
the video.
So let's just see if you can put together those reading English.
Yeah.
The reading,
this is popping up on the screen to them.
Okay.
Cool.
Class to sound like go,
go see.
Say Kansas.
Sit,
wait,
something about Godzilla and pussy or something like that.
Well,
you're close.
You're getting better at this.
It's weird how you're better at these.
And the other ones just have to squint really hard and I could hear it yet.
This,
uh,
she said my queens sound like Godzilla.
Taking a shit.
Oh,
cool.
[inaudible] sound like
go,
go.
See they kick us.
Sit.
Very worried about that.
What she's pronouncing or the way you guys it Godzilla.
It's in Japanese is Gojira,
but she's pronouncing the way white people would.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
So in weight in Japan is not God's will.
It's good euro means it's a combination of we're gorilla.
Yup.
Could you wrote which is well,
so Godzilla is while breathing like a gorilla.
Well that's,
yeah.
What about Queef?
I've never thought of it that way.
It's fantastic.
What about Queef?
What's the Japanese word for them?
Uh,
Fukushima.
That's a big one.
We all do
quite good.
Yeah.
Can you do that again?
I don't do that one.
Yeah.
Where do we go
there quite yet?
Yeah.
Something about gimme your decor.
No,
it's little yellow dicks.
Big White Dick's.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll just skip that one.
Hold on.
No,
no one was amazing with that because she was six years old.
Oh my God.
Hold on.
This one maybe you didn't get this one.
Hold on,
right.
Oh my God.
Nothing.
Something about my pussy.
That's all I,
yeah,
you're right.
My Pussy has more folds that my eyelids.
Oh,
okay.
Nice.
Oh my God.
That's got to be my cell phone.
Huh?
The holidays ladies has so funny.
My Pussy.
Huh?
How about this one?
I leave
means Lilo
something yellow.
Yellow.
This is,
please
rub your manmade on my yellow pig face.
Oh my God.
Oh my
Jesus Christ.
Fuck man.
This one's weird.
I mean they're all weird,
but this one.
How about this one?
Turning into the person.
You might be able to get this one.
I'm sorry.
Turning into a blog person.
Something about black,
black pussy.
No,
I'm slowly turning into a black person.
Oh,
I dunno.
Why?
Committing crimes.
Yeah.
God Damn it.
Can I fix your rice whole?
Did you get that one?
Oh Man,
I don't,
I've heard rice house before.
Yeah.
Wow.
This,
this show went way harder than the early show.
Yeah.
No.
So far.
You're not doing so well at this time.
I'm really bad with everything.
No,
no,
you're not disappointed.
I'm just kidding.
And this is really good.
Hey,
so I wanted to ask you this,
my rights fees
with these medical experiments,
have you ever had any ill side effects at all?
Cause he,
wait,
so people know.
I mean I thought it was clear,
but just in case you don't know,
he signs up for like the medical testing.
So like when a new,
like a new medication comes out,
they have to make sure,
you know,
has certain side effects and
time when you have medication.
One time another itch been tried on animals and people and then,
uh,
last,
um,
it's funny,
it next week is five years losing my job at evil angel.
Right.
And,
um,
I've done,
you know,
I'm making off some money doing standup,
but there's time I'm low on cash.
So,
um,
this medical testing places look for people from Japan to try these medication
and yeah,
last three and a half,
four years.
I don't know.
I've done shitload of um,
medical testing.
Um,
the worst thing that ever happened to me is I,
I wouldn't even say where's my shit turn into green for like two and a half
months.
It was like green.
Yeah.
It's a little like a Yoshi,
the green dinosaur coming out of my ass.
All right.
Yeah.
Did it hurt or was it loose or was it the same one?
What was here?
Because every time we get tested by doctor they say,
are you experiencing any adverse effect?
Nobody would say anything.
Like I don't want to be the first guy to say might because I could be the only
one.
My Shit is turning green.
And then of course I told them of course then everybody and met the fact that
they're the,
why do I have to be the first guy to tell you my shit is green?
But the worst thing was I was in group one and there was a group too.
They're all Japanese.
Two different medication.
And my roommate and I were reading,
I think,
I don't think I told you I'm a,
maybe I'm repeating the story,
but I'm having breakfast three days later after,
um,
chicken in the guy we checked in,
but he was in group too.
He sat next to us and I look and turned orange.
I mean he,
oh wow.
The orange spot in circular motion everywhere and his face,
arms,
legs.
And I asked him in Japanese like,
are your orange between the legs?
He goes,
hi.
Which is Japanese,
but yes.
And um,
and I don't want to laugh at him.
It's funny,
you know,
cause he looked like Japanese Kool aid guy walking in there.
Right.
And he wants in and add insult to injury.
If you,
if you have adverse effects now when did you get kicked out of the study?
Right away you get you,
they make less money so you kind of fuck and like I don't know what happened
that they just kick all those people out of there.
Um,
we didn't have any problem,
you know,
that's not fair to get kicked out because of something they did.
Well,
I mean,
they can't continue to give them drugs.
They have to stop you.
They get paid.
So a minus a day.
So they didn't serve.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
But other than that,
I have a hat,
like illegal magazine.
I wrote a article and uh,
uh,
I'll,
I'll finally have copies for the US market,
but it's the story that I wrote and it's like a subculture.
It's really strange.
There'll be times like,
oh,
we'll go screening for study.
And I'm seeing like,
oh,
I remember you.
You're your liver cancer 2013.
You know,
when you go comedy show,
see someone sending you haven't seen for a while.
And so all these guys literally traveled the country doing one medical testing
after I just stayed in southern California.
But I'm in travel the country doing it.
Yeah.
It's like fight club,
except I call the stomach sports.
And um,
you literally have to have a stomach gut to do it.
But it's like,
we're like
blood brothers because we still our blood to make money.
Right.
So,
but,
but there's,
there's,
there's a lot of that medical testing places here.
It's called Cro,
clinical research organization.
And everyone's gonna be off on you.
It,
if,
you know,
if you,
if you need money you could comment on
and it's not the worst thing I guess.
Yeah.
Bad things can happen.
Um,
so the worst thing you could do,
and it's true,
we got an email where somebody said,
uh,
I was watching the sopranos that somebody wrote recently.
It season one episode eight 45 minutes in the residents of a nursing home or
watching a terrible standup comedian.
I've heard of road comics,
corporate gigs,
et Cetera.
But I've,
I've hadn't heard of a nursing home circuit.
Is that a real thing?
Matthew writes that that is definitely a real thing.
The circuit a circuit occasional.
Absolutely.
Any place that it's possible to have a show they are,
there are shows,
but they're terrible at like 1:00 PM or noon.
Oh yeah.
It's not fun to do this
worst Gig you've had like daytime gig.
Oh my God,
he would is colony,
nudist colony and everyone that you want to see naked or not naked.
And the people that you don't want to see naked,
they're really sit front and they're so confident they're sending like this.
Right.
I could see their rice holes and rice
hall.
Those are uncomfortable nudist colony.
Really?
Yeah.
It's off of 10th freeway literal before you get on the 15 and a,
I'm not making that up.
I Wa if you gave me stage time,
I'll fucking show up.
And um,
I've done those.
I've done women's prison.
Uh,
sounds fine.
Now they're there.
They're very nice.
Um,
women's thing,
like a halfway house when they're just out of prison.
Is that what that is?
Transitional home.
And I remember being like,
how many of you girls are married and all of them had like either like abusive
husbands are like,
had been put away for VI domestic violence yet.
And I was like,
Oh yeah.
Oh,
they're married to someone in prison as well.
So fucked up.
I felt so bad.
I was like,
target.
Am I right?
Like I did not relate.
Things are getting too exciting.
Let's dial it down.
Bring it down.
I'm here to talk to you today
or engineered grassy depressions designed to detain large volumes of storm water
after rain events cause wanted to play something boring for a second so I don't
want to do
anyway can do this one.
When you yellow,
when you yellow unzip the flight.
This is interesting.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
This is really important.
Hi,
Mommy's email,
right?
Yeah.
My brother and I are both huge fans.
The show,
and we're talking a while ago about our yellowing habits and thought you guys
could weigh in.
We listened that some men at our jobs only unzipped the fly of their genes and
bring their weaner through the zipper hole button and belt still fastened to
yellow.
However,
my brother and I have corroborated that we both unzipped the fly and undo belt
button,
etc. Then take our wiener out above the waist band of our me undies,
thus maximizing the distance from our dicks to zipper teeth after speaking for a
little bit longer,
we thought it was a generational thing.
Both me and my brother are poly by millennials and most of the men we each work
with are cisgender dads.
But even after talking with some of my likeminded millennial friends,
I've noticed that some of them also pull the snake through the whole,
like the aforementioned cisgendered dads.
Thanks.
From Charlotte,
North Carolina.
Nate,
that is a fantastic email.
Interesting discussion.
Really thought provoking.
Pulled a wiener just through the zipper or do you open it and take everything?
The twig and the berries out of
me.
Yeah.
Tell me.
I feel like it's a fuck.
It feels like a boss move to grab everything and drop it out.
So I like to the whole thing and let the whole package out.
You know,
I don't just weasel the story.
Kind of afraid of getting your penis stuck in the zipper?
Never really think about that.
I don't think about that.
No.
You think about that?
I've done that before.
Yeah.
Maybe the Zipper is difficult.
Yeah,
I mean who hasn't,
I guess it's happened,
but not with a free weight.
Do you wear boxers or underwear?
Um,
what do I wait sometime I wrote him where anything,
well,
yeah,
that's,
that would be the answer.
So then it becomes a problem.
Yeah.
And those are the times when you get scared.
Scared.
Well,
don't your pubes get caught in your zipper to Asian people are not that hairy
doe that's trail.
It's,
you know,
I would love to shave my body and cover you and all that.
Oh,
we could probably sell that on something,
right?
Yeah.
We patch it on you.
Let's do it.
I,
I'll,
I'll pay you medical testing rate.
Let's do it.
But you have to wear his body here.
Yeah.
And you got to where every inch of it.
You know,
you know our good friend Russell Peters,
right?
Yeah.
Is East Indian.
So,
um,
his word Indian.
Yeah.
He's got hair on top of his hair and he's a hairy dude.
Right.
He knows I don't like body hair.
He just,
he'll come up and just kind of glaze.
He's got w what are you fucking monkeys?
But he has,
um,
he's got,
what do you call this area goes,
yes.
Sorry.
I know rice hall,
but I don't know this part.
Okay.
Um,
he's got here on knuckles.
That's disgusting.
I kept,
he just calming,
kind of,
I dunno.
Glaze is Harry fucking hands all over me and like that I'm not into body here.
I mean really no,
because if I have,
if I see here on my foot,
I was fucking shape that shut off.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't like,
that's disgusting.
So have you ever been to the hairy woman?
Cause I know you've been with a lot of women.
See sometimes there's hookers or like they deceive you because they kinda
covered their bodies.
So you think,
oh she's not Harry and like Oh my God,
I just the I don't like hairy pussy.
Right.
That's a fair thing.
No,
some of his,
some of his fine,
but you know,
you didn't want to look like a fucking Mr t down there.
Right.
So,
um,
pity the fool.
Right.
So anyway.
All right,
well yeah,
I mean it is a matter of preference.
Like your dad is a full Bush guy cause he's from the yes.
Thank you for reminding me.
I have that him and my dad is full Bush guy.
Yeah.
He told me that once.
That was fucking horrible memory that I thought was gone.
What a great time though to be a woman.
Like the 70s,
the 80s do just full Bush.
Yeah.
You have fucking wax or think about it.
I say we go back
bull ball.
He this guy.
He likes it.
Yeah.
Right.
Dad.
How old?
How old are you?
Okay.
Are You Hungarian?
Oh,
okay.
It'd be gates.
Can I tell you something?
Can I do something that is my great friend Steve Holmes,
the greatest German porn site.
Oh,
that should
give it up for Steve.
Is he a strong performer?
He is.
I call him the Larry Bird.
A pornography.
I'm telling you,
too many young punks in this business these days,
they cheat.
They use medication days.
They put a cap or Jack that shit today and Jack Andrews in their dicks and stuff
and they're cheaters.
Not this man.
I saw,
I met him 15 years ago in a,
um,
I think it was a vns and Berlin and Barcelona erotic film festival.
And he was on stage live six shell fucking this women on stage.
I mean,
you think comedy stop you trying to fuck three girls on stage when thousand
people screaming,
yelling,
oh no,
this guy's a professional medicine.
Give it off to Steve Holmes.
He's like,
I love this guy.
Wow.
Here's the first one to call me.
Make sure I was okay when I lost my job.
You know,
because it's not,
it has nothing to do with his being German.
And I'm from Japan,
World War Two.
It has nothing to do with,
uh,
he's a great friend.
So many of you picked him.
I knew how funny I was drawn to his full.
And you're still working right?
You're still working.
Oh yes.
The Germans.
Are they big into body here or do they,
do they embrace a full Bush?
Is that why you're,
you love to see it come back?
He said that he likes to see it coming back.
That more and more women are full blushing.
I agree.
Fuck waxing.
It's so painful.
I wouldn't even wax my legs.
I wouldn't put that shit on my meow.
No Way.
So wait,
did you say you're 55 55 years old and still working and do you have any decline
in your,
uh,
desires to know every same thing?
You're just like a 16 year old kid.
Yeah.
Oh,
the girl stay young.
He said she's a star in the business as well.
All right.
Tom Brady.
Hey Justin.
He doesn't lose anything.
This guy,
he's in the porn Superbowl right here,
man.
Then what's your last smells like coconut oil smell like
that's where my pup play
stamina.
I've been getting trained anima.
Stan Ama that forever.
Anybody say it wrong completely now because of that.
Yeah.
Has that guy then we don't even know which one is right.
Yes.
Damn men as right.
Yeah.
Stamina's right?
He's all staying on them.
Anima
fucking asshole.
I can't even get it right now.
Fuck that guy.
I played them twice and I still go stand down once it's in there.
I tried to correct somebody too.
I tried to correct somebody and I said it with confidence incorrectly.
Like somebody says stem and I got it.
Thank you.
Mean stand standing ma.
And then they were like,
I don't,
I think you're right.
Wait,
who's right?
Stan [inaudible].
Stan Umma stamina.
Fuck Nick my ass.
Have you ever met Rocco's to Freddy Rocco?
Yeah,
Steve has worked with were good buds and I had like one conversation with him.
All right.
She's this.
I found them talking.
Would you be,
would you be in here?
This is so small.
Would you be interested in having him on your hill?
Oh No,
I'm just to stay married.
You know what I mean?
Now you can have on the show.
I talked to him too.
He was already like,
okay,
let's have him on.
Yeah,
we're going to have mine.
I'll make it happen.
Well,
my dinner with them.
What?
Are you going to send them?
A fucking postcard or something?
Is he in Hungary?
Is he still married?
A Hungarian lady.
Wow.
You do?
I'm telling you.
We taught all she knows her shit.
No Rock,
huh?
No,
no.
We're not together.
You're right.
His wife is on Garren.
She's beautiful.
Yeah,
I know.
Okay.
I'm just going on.
What is your penis situation like?
What do you mean?
Oh,
like medical tests.
Does it affect it or,
okay.
Yeah.
Is that what I know the,
what was the question?
It is now.
Oh sure.
Yeah.
We weren't even going to go there.
Does it affect your penis?
No,
I mean I haven't,
I mean I'm 47 so it's not like you're 47.
Freezy great man.
You look great for having bureau fucking Guinea pig.
Jesus Christ.
You look great.
Well,
ironically,
I think the medical testing that force me to keep healthy because I have to
watch my weight,
you know,
and uh,
half to walk every day and um,
it's quiet.
Nobody if you,
if you want to loose weight during medical tests,
it's a,
one of the best way because I remember over the summer I was 31 days.
I was literally losing almost pound a day because the low Carolee calorie intake
study in like,
I didn't even serve porn to whole time.
I was there because I was surfing for food and the W,
you know,
because I was thinking this is going,
what I'm going to eat when I get the fuck Outta here first.
Now I'm going to do another weight loss contest and I'm going to go to medical
testing.
You know,
you will lose weight.
I mean,
there's no way around it.
I a couple of times almost,
I got teary thinking about food because I was so hungry.
I was,
yeah,
no,
I understand.
Have you seen,
uh,
what's your latest prostitutes situation?
Where have you been somewhere on a trip lately?
I was in,
um,
I was,
I was in Europe for illegal magazine and we were trying to help the street
hookers in the Copenhagen and places like that.
But,
um,
when I was in Amsterdam,
I was going to,
I was supposed to get paid,
but I didn't get paid before my trip,
so I have very little money.
So when I was in Amsterdam,
I had little money.
I guess I could have gone a prostitute,
but you know,
I was so busy watching.
Have you ever watched that show?
Um,
bojack horseman
on Netflix?
That,
I'm not kidding if you haven't seen it,
that she made me cry.
Uh,
I watched the whole fucking thing three,
four times,
the whole three seasons.
It's telling you thing three or four times a three seasons of it.
I'm telling you,
I know you,
if you see a horse,
his face,
he think that's stupid,
but you should,
I'm telling you,
it's one of the greatest show ever about addiction and living in Hollywood and
uh,
dealing with a celebrity culture.
It's like,
no,
I'm telling you,
if you see it,
that shit,
it was just such a hard thing to watch,
but it was a,
well,
our name was just brilliant.
This,
it's a beautiful show and issue.
You should,
I'm telling you right.
I didn't even get hooker.
Oh my God.
Look,
a lot of you,
uh,
have,
participated and sent in your,
uh,
hey mommy's thanks jeans.
And they've been,
every week they get better and better.
We,
uh,
we,
we pulled a couple to play here for you because they,
people have been building on them.
So I'm going to play,
uh,
some of the latest submissions we even had.
I can't show you here,
but we had a police officer do one,
which is fucking amazing that a cop in uniform pulled up in his police car and
was like,
Hi Mommy.
And then a hole,
which we both got terrified when we saw the video come in.
We were like,
oh,
you're little gene nonsense,
but it's not so sure this one says,
okay.
Uh,
just a heads up.
You guys have the Pastrami Sandwich.
Tray money.
Yeah.
All right,
Jean is,
um,
can I get a Pastrami Sandwich?
You want anything Burke?
Uh,
let me see.
I'm just glassing here.
Um,
no,
that'd be all mommy.
Just a Pastrami Sandwich,
right?
Thanks.
I love you.
He gave such a confident high,
hit the out loud.
He says it just came out with that Hitler,
Hitler,
Uhh,
some people mask it,
you know,
they go like,
hey there,
how are you doing now let me get this guy.
It's confident,
man.
No,
it's a German guy laughing.
Um,
just one second.
I'm just glassing.
I know what I want.
How do I south,
um,
can I have a Venti Chai please?
With a two splendas and adult pipe classic and a little bit of one,
a extra shot of espresso.
Any breakfast today?
Uh,
no.
I don't want you to sound like I'm thinking mommy.
Awesome.
That's all I need.
Okay.
Thanks jeans.
Amazing.
So good.
Yes.
That's amazing.
Uh,
we were at islands a dining on their fine burgers today at the mall.
We both got diarrhea and
on our way out.
Well,
to be fair,
I started the day with diarrhea.
Who fucking does that?
Who starts the day and then goes,
let's eat it.
Islands for fucking lunch was not my suggestion.
I was your idea.
And we get here and she's like,
I want the hummus from the plant.
I go,
you know what's going to happen to your insides right now?
It's a stupid,
yeah.
Fuck.
Anyway,
on the way out of islands,
one of the waiters goes,
uh,
thanks jeans.
Yeah,
that's so cool.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Like I said it over
and I go by Hitler.
Yeah.
Mommy.
Thanks Jane.
So we had this one other,
I love the Dad boner for clips,
you know,
and um,
these are the best,
this is a rocket dad.
He sees a like a,
a rocket,
like a one,
you know one of those ad.
Yeah,
we said like there's whale,
Dad Boehner and there's a,
what is the other?
The super of the Odyssey.
The train guy?
Yeah.
The foam or Boehner.
There's a moose hunter boner.
This guy sees a,
like a little toy rocket being shot up.
Nice.
Okay.
That's a fucking dad boner right there.
Can you play the glass and guy here was,
I thought that was your reason one.
I like that.
Okay.
The original guy,
this guy
just glass.
Yeah.
I don't know.
His whole thing is,
I don't know where it's at.
Yeah,
there so loose
he gets so
fucking xls.
Hard fucking clue.
I don't know where that goes.
Um,
we uh,
we have to wrap the show up.
Um,
play it out while you're doing that night.
Cause I was just going through this boar.
Okay,
then don't play that one.
What do you mean to play?
I don't know.
No,
that's a ice Jj fish right there.
Yeah,
there's
classics.
Classic.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
man.
There's Yoshi [inaudible] man.
Like a son to me.
I don't know other,
the,
the ultimate dat.
It's like,
I like that one.
That's when the dad gets real excited in his face.
Hits all the buttons on the phone.
One of my favorites is that we talk some shit.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well let's talk some shit.
Talk a little bit about the white tigers practices.
I don't want to get to him today.
Oh my gosh.
We're going deep.
Ready?
Yes.
Alright.
Um,
genes.
Thank you very much for coming into this coming or we had a blast doing it.
First of all,
how about a round of applause for our guests,
Yoshi.
Okay.
Bye.
[inaudible] guys.
Rob Doing your shows.
You guys are always been good to me.
You're the best.
He's absolutely one of our favorites.
And,
um,
and no,
seriously,
we always have a great time with you.
Thank you for doing it.
You guys though,
uh,
who are,
who we owe a huge thanks to for,
for listening to the show every week for coming out to events like this,
these,
this show tonight and the earlier show.
We'll both be downloadable episodes,
but it's,
it's you guys that make it possible.
So thank you guys very much.
You guys for coming out.
Have a wonderful night,
uh,
on the way out.
Have a great night.
Thank you for making that gene.
Goodnight.
Thank you guys.
Get
the
hello.